[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kel West and here I have no other then
what the Prince of power himself he-man
the most powerful man in the universe
it's kind of crazy right that uh we get
these characters I just brought you
Skeletor and now I'm bringing you he man
and these are characters that we grew up
with watching them in various stages of
transformations and cartoons well this
is sideshows he-man and I believe he's
one-fifth scale it's nice right this is
sideshows reimagining of the character
now normally you will have a character
that looks like the new piece I think is
a PCP versus a PCE PSC version of he-man
this one right here and I was going to
go for that one the battle cat also as
you can see is a available at sideshow
but I wanted the exclusive version so
I'm probably on a wait list I don't know
if I'm gonna pull the trigger on those
because I have a he-man and Skeletor and
I like the new reimagining of it because
that's how they would look if they were
coming out in 2020 or 2019 and they have
an uncle I want to pick up the character
I think they had them for like $200 on
sideshow but um I remember coming home
from school having my bowl of cereal
sitting down watching he-man vs.
Skeletor watching uh Prince Adam you
know defend uh you know the Castle
Grayskull this this stuff is so
fantastic to having to collect and to be
part of this great community it's insane
and this is mixed-media talk to you guys
about mixed-media so you understand how
mixed-media goes but this one is a
little bit more special because his
power weapon his the Power Sword is
actually metal right and the level of
detail if you look at it right here is
nice it's very meticulously done it's
not too many moving parts on this statue
he has his shield he has a sword on the
exclusive edition he has an axe
so yeah it's a very good statute the
same way the Skeletor is a very good
statue the detail is immense as a
sideshow put their spin on it and it
gives you that old-school flavor with a
new school funk to it you know you can
really enjoy a very it's very pleasing
to look at and when you have both
statutes together its outstanding
I'm probably gonna do a versus one day
you know protagonist versus antagonist I
have a lot of other sessions to get
through once I get through those statues
then we're gonna be cooking with
something new I don't like to introduce
a new formats until after we finish all
this stuff first right and then we can
get into teams you can get into Avengers
versus defenders or The Avengers versus
the Justice League there's some more
pieces with the Justice League that's
that I have to pick up or we can get
into he-man vs. Thundercats
remember I already showed you mum Row 3
so jewel I know
so I showed you Skeletor now that's true
I'm showing you a man so we can have a
whole
big statue jambalaya
of different topics and different hour
versus you know and it's very
interesting
we're in exciting times sideshows
picking up satchel collecting is picking
up and I had to get my hands on this
statute it was something about it that
made me want to pull the trigger on it
and it was warranted it has a conan feel
to it as a real-life feel to it and I
think they really hit it out the park
when they did this one so listen guys
this is part of the video what I'm going
to tell you to like follow subscribe and
also pull the Lords of gaming dotnet
well we have tons of opinion pieces we
have tons of articles that's up there we
have hard gaming reviews with Lord
addict we have Lord kognito Andy Von
Teese with the last word for all your
looter shooter news and we also have
other episodes of care Wes so you can
tune in get those other episodes of care
Wes and also watch combat talk with the
king where I go into depth about boxing
some MMA and I might do a lot of
celebrity fights too as well so check us
out there stick around watch the rest of
the video where you can see this statue
in all its glory
pictures and videos and listen some cool
move music without listening to this guy
so take care guys see you next week
and always stay collected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]